what kind of revolves around you going
on a school trip to Europe yes it does
yeah the film is a direct continuation
of avengers endgame so we deal with the
ramifications if the blip of the death
of Tony Stark sorry to anyone who hasn't
seen the film if you haven't then you're
living under a rock you were in it
so the story is basically spider-man
trying to take a break
he's trying to hang up the spider-man
suit and escape the responsibility of
being a superhero but what he learns
throughout the course of the film is
that that responsibility isn't something
you can run away from and that's when we
team up and we sort of become best buds
on an off-screen
[Laughter]
and we've got these elemental creatures
Jake Tom it sounds like was quite
unsympathetic to you while you were
filming would you get a little a little
peaky oh yeah we were shooting as well
we were shooting a scene and I got a I
got I got sick I was very nauseous
throughout the day and and in the middle
of the one of the takes I I I threw up
in the middle of the take and kept going
you know but that's how that's what
acting is all about
I was sitting opposite him and I was
like how is he doing that he's so good
he looks so tortured and so unwell and
so I'm so like like hurt and then he
basically just had a stomach bug and
they actually CGI'd the vomit out of the
shot but if you look in the movie in the
movie at there's my house just partially
open at one I'm kidding
[Applause]
that's the Marvel Universe painting out
the vomit
wait some but my eyes were so expressive
[Music]
you